howard how we're doing it and we've got
the army we've got
pharmacists we've got a huge nhs
operation
we've got hospital sites we've got mass
vaccination centers
um but i think it's reasonable uh that
as soon as we get
regional good regional data for instance
we should be sharing that as well and
uh we're going to be publishing as soon
as possible uh later this week we'll be
publishing the regional breakdowns and
uh and i can tell you that some of the
figures are very interesting you know
there
the there are parts of the country where
they're
there they've done incredibly well uh in
for instance vaccinating the over 80s
uh 50 more than 50 well whatever 50
now in uh in in the northeast and
yorkshire less good in some other parts
of the country
so we want to be clear about all that
and a crucial thing
is that we want the the data about those
who have been vaccinated
in local authorities to be shared and it
will happen by the end of this week
with public health directors in local
uh in local authorities because as
we go forward uh this vaccine
program is going to find that there are
people that we need to reach
uh that we can only reach uh with uh
with
the nhs working hand in glove uh with
local government
i mean it's my mother's not that i want
to reveal she's over 80 but she had her
vaccine this morning in surrey but i
have no idea
how many other people were vaccinated in
surrey so i wonder if you could possibly
look into whether we could actually
release that data by local authority
area because i think it would be
very interesting and just finally one
other bit of data which is very
important is the wastage because every
person who is not vaccinated because of
waste
is potentially put in peril so could we
look at publishing wastage rates
by vaccination center just to encourage
everyone to treat
each vaccine very preciously but we'll
try and publish as much data as we
as we can uh on on on there's a very
important point about wastage
um which is that
we want in this in this stage when our
big constraint is
is supply of the vaccine uh we want to
absolutely to minimize
waste and so um that that's people say
well why don't you get
uh you know all of the 9 000 maybe 12
000
uh community pharmacies to be doing this
because they're fantastic they
you know they're they're wonderful
people uh they uh
they they've got clean premises and so
on and so forth uh they could do it the
trouble there
and it's very important people
understand you you logistically you'd
have
our teams going around dropping off
supplies of a vaccine
uh in uh in you know twelve thousand
idol nine thousand outlets
and then at the end of each evening
you'd have a proportion
uh that were not used still in the
fridge and the risk is that
when we're still constrained by supply
we don't want that happening at this
stage but
as we go forward um with the with the
rollout and
uh as i say as we as we as we really dig
into those groups that
uh not yet come forward don't know uh
how to do it
uh then i think community pharmacies uh
which are trusted uh well known uh will
play an important part in
uh in the rollout but
on local authority publications we'll
we'll do whatever we can the moment the
plan is for regional breakdown the
regional breakdown is very interesting
uh thank you uh jeremy and thank you uh
prime minister
on the wastage front my local hospital
uh
had uh targeted uh
nhs workers standing by to use up any
spare vaccine at the end of every
session
even though they're not officially on
the priority list other hospitals have
not done that
and they have been wasting vaccine can
we promote best practice
yes and it's perhaps also worth saying
that
there is a big or there can be
differences
in the amount of a vaccine that
you vile the the the quantity of vaccine
that is necessary
to vaccinate a given number of people
depending on the
skill of the vaccinator and that's why
in these early stages we really want to
to maximize the use of of people who uh
are very very proficient in uh in giving
the vaccinations now we all understand
prime minister that the
the committee's asked me to ask these
questions um that
there are limitations on the vaccine
supply
and there is an agreed schedule of
delivery
um but what steps is the government
taking to increase the supply
over the agreed schedule beyond the
agreed schedule so we can accelerate the
whole program
well sir bernard as you know there's a
uh that this government has
secured a bigger supply of vaccines uh i
think both absolutely and the head
than uh virtually any other country in
the in the world so we have a big
big stream of vaccines uh
uh coming uh down the track but um
the there is also a
a program to accelerate the delivery of
of of the the oxford uh vaccine
uh the the so the remaining pfizer
vaccine is being
has been brought forward uh the moderna
vaccine
as well uh we're doing everything we can
to
to bring forward the manufacturing uh
process as fast as we can so that we can
start getting it into people's arms uh
in the timeless way
um and um there has been some concern
that um
the it was reported to the society
technology committee this meeting
this morning astrazeneca actually
requested that
their technicians and production workers
should be prioritized for the vaccine
so that they don't suffer the sickness
rates that they're suffering at the
moment
that would seem important to uh and
critical to the vaccine program
could you yes i mean you're making an
excellent point and
um the the uh as you as the committee
knows the jcbi
has set up the nine uh the the the cat
of the
rankings of nine groups we're starting
with the first four
uh groups by by february the 15th um
uh we will in in general leave the
decisions about which groups should uh
be prioritized to the
joint committee on vaccination and
immunization i'm sure that's the right
thing to do
but clearly when it comes to the
manufacture of the vaccines
there is a critical role for those those
workers and that
has to be taken into consideration and
in terms of the
of delivering the programme uh the mod
confirmed yesterday they could deploy up
to 10 000 people if necessary
and they so far only
one-third of the personnel on standby
have been
uh deployed
an additional ten thousand uh can you
confirm that that
offer is available to wales northern
ireland and scotland
if they're getting behind with their
programs and they need that capacity
of course and i can say that the armed
services of the of the uk
are on deployment uh throughout the
uk as they have been throughout the the
pandemic and
uh the uh there is there are there are
plans to
uh to step up uh the involvement of
they're already embedded at virtually
every level the armed services
in the in the vaccine rollout program
but that we will step that up as
as uh as the distribution uh campaign
accelerates as i say at the moment
that's not the constraint well
um the nhs england is
recruiting uh new people um
re-rolling nhs staff to vaccination
program
and at the moment refusing the offer of
the
mods trained up vaccine quick reaction
teams
which would seem to be a sensible use of
resource at this particular moment
well that's that's not my information i
and i i was
in a long session yesterday with both
the army and the
uh and the nhs and as you know brigadier
phil prosser
and others are uh uh integrated at
the highest level and uh the armed
services are being of great use but that
will
that will increase as the as the as the
tempo grows but the um there's a very
painful process for a local nhs team to
do to get a maca request through the nhs
system as we've discovered in essex once
already perhaps you can just take that
one away
i'll certainly have a look at that uh on
local authorities and i'm going to come
to clive betts
from the hclg committee in a moment
we know that local authorities should
have been involved in the test and trace
program much earlier
and that was a mistake so why nhs
england officials according to many of
my colleagues our colleagues
being instructed not to share
information with partners
about vaccine locations and things like
that
so undermining trust and cooperation
when we
should all be pulling together in this
massive emergency well
my you're absolutely right that it's
vital
that the nhs and local authorities
collaborate in this
and i think all colleagues will be
familiar with the experience of
uh local friction uh between uh the nhs
and
uh and local authorities in in some
cases we will have come across that
uh it's vital that they work together uh
but also that the nhs
shares data about uh who has been
vaccinated and who hasn't
because as i say uh there are there will
be groups
uh who are hard to reach uh particularly
from the black and minority ethnic
community uh possibly we're seeing some
evidence of
of that and it is vital that we have
a strong local community engagement
as we as we go towards the really high
numbers
that we find everybody who needs a
vaccine and and encourage them to
to take it thank you clive betts
um thank you uh bernard good afternoon
prime minister
um prime minister you
the national audit office has done a
review
of the national um tracing system
uh and has said that before the
uh the call centers were set up uh to
track people who got covered and their
contacts
there was no business case done no value
for money assessment
has one been done now um
well i i think uh
clive the uh the business case for
uh testing uh tracking and tracing
uh is is overwhelming and it's it's to
do with
uh with saving lives yeah but
but given the the national system uh
they're successful in contacting about
60 of the people they're trying to
contact
but when the uh the ones they can't
contact the 40
are passed over to local councils
they're contacting 75
or more of those people a much higher
ratio
for much less cost wouldn't it make
sense to transfer more of the
responsibility
and more of the resources to local
councils and directors of public health
well uh if contrary to perhaps to the to
the widespread impression
uh local councils have been involved
from the from the very beginning
and uh they've done an outstanding job
but i also think that nhs test and trace
overall
they've tested i didn't know the
community as well they've tested 56
million people
or they've conducted a bachelor's degree
they conducted 56 million
tests and that is an astonishing number
i believe it's the highest in uh
in in europe and although
clearly it's been extremely difficult to
control the the disease by test and
trace alone
it has played an important part and we
would not
know uh some of the vital things we do
know
about for instance the uh the the new
variant or
the south african variant uh if we
weren't doing a massive daily genomics
thanks to nhs tests and traits
right but the the reality of prime
minister is that it's less successful at
national level than it is at local level
in actually contacting people so i'm
asking for a switch
of the program in that regard not that
we shouldn't be doing
uh tracking and tracing but we could do
it better at local level
you say that local authorities have been
involved in the beginning that's not
their impression
and i want to come on now to the
comments you made to jeremy hunt and to
the chair about local authority
involvement in the vaccine program
the local government chronicle ran a
story the other day with the support of
local council leaders and directors of
public health
saying there was a wall of silence in
the nhs
they were getting no data about what was
happening with regard to vaccinations in
their area
and they need that data for example and
you just referenced it
to contact particularly hard-to-reach
groups people people in the bme
community where take-up may be lower
and to get communications out there but
they don't know how many vaccines have
been
delivered in which parts of their area
will that change us from next week
it will change this week and as i said
to sir bernard earlier
or i think to jeremy um by the end of
this week i want
uh public health directors in local
government
to know uh who has been vaccinated in
uh in their communities it's going to be
essential as we go forward
uh that the local authorities know who's
been vaccinated and can
uh can can can lead the fight in in
their areas
so that we're down to individual data so
that there could be an assessment say
of clinical clinically extremely
vulnerable people who haven't haven't
been vaccinated
uh of care workers who haven't haven't
been vaccinated that detailed
information will be available to
councils
and directors of public health that's
exactly right
that's really helpful practice can i
also say is it
now going to be the case that local
authorities are going to be involved in
the planning of the vaccine rollout
program they can help with identifying
appropriate sites
they can help generally with
communications um
they can do an awful lot of things
working conjunction in sheffield
there is really good working
relationships between the council
the ccg and the hospitals will that now
be unable to happen by uh by the
national health services at national
level
stop putting blockages in the way of
data sharing yes
uh it will and my experience is that um
and
obviously it may not be identical across
the uh across the country but my ex the
the examples i've been given of uh uh
the the
similar ones you quote of of of local
authorities
uh really pulling out all the stops to
help the nhs to find the sites to get
things going
and you know you're making a very good
point about data we've got to have that
data
properly shared and what i'd be just
to repeat and clarify what i've been
assured
is that local authorities will get data
about all the people
who have been vaccinated uh by the end
of this week
now that will obviously need to be
continually
refreshed and updated of course it will
i just want one final point then uh
looking to the the future what will the
uh information be available to local
authorities
uh and to the public about what is going
to happen with regard to
future sites and future rollout uh just
from my own point of view i was refused
information the other day
about which sites were going to be open
in sheffield i was told that they
had to go to the top of nhs england for
that information to be released
isn't it no don't we need to take the
public into our confidence
and give them the information so they
they can have an awareness
of what is happening in their area yes
uh climb i think the the
the issue there may be that uh we want
to
allow the system to to make the decision
about
which sites are going to be uh to be
used and
uh and then working with local
government working with all the
stakeholders
uh together uh before getting into a
a public uh debate or a perhaps or
argument about it but but there will be
a continual expansion as you know i
think there are
uh about uh more than a thousand primary
care network
uh operations going on about 233
hospitals
as i said before 200 uh pharmacies
uh and 50 mass vaccination sites and
clearly the the exact location for
instance of the mass vaccination sites
will be a subject of keen
uh public interest and debate it's
important to get it right
it is but i think that the presumption
should be prime minister then that as
much information as possible
should be made publicly available as
quickly as possible i completely agree
particularly as the as the public
accounts committee learned that the
assumption in your program is that there
needs to be 75
take up of the vaccine to hit the
targets and
getting that 75 as the program
progresses is going to get harder and
harder unless everybody's cooperating
that subverted you put you put your
finger on the on the point
for the vaccine program to be as
successful as we want it to be
uh we must ensure that uh people uh are
encouraged
to come forward for for testing and and
they have every reason to be confident
and
and happy and in doing so actually some
of the
we're seeing some very encouraging data
showing that people are more and more
enthusiastic
about being vaccinated uh rather than uh
than the reverse and just very briefly
one word answer required
when will we know whether the those
vaccinated
are safe to let out that they can't
spread the
the virus when will we know that vaccine
actually enables people to go back to
their daily lives well i think what i
can't tell you about transmission
yet uh but as soon as we have that data
we'll uh of course be publishing thank
you robert halford
uh thank you prime minister um apart
from directing these food companies
possibly to spec savers who have been
supplying
schools with less than uh proportionate
food boxes
will you not just take these companies
to task but given that they've ripped
off the
taxpayer make sure that the schools get
a refund but also
look at the public guidance um
that in terms of food to vulnerable
children
yes thanks rob your your your right to
be
obviously outraged by the uh the images
that we
we've seen in the um uh the companies
uh in questionable certain the one the
one of the most
notorious uh pictures uh the company
responsible for that
uh and others have been hauled over the
uh the coals asked to explain how this
has happened they've
they've apologized and they have
reimbursed the schools concerned and
pledged not to
and not to do it again i should stress
that the um
the images do not reflect the actual
government
guidance uh which which is for about
double the quantity of
food for lunch packs for for five days
that uh
uh that um uh uh
you've seen uh if not more
um but uh it's vital that people
you know understand that this government
is is that uh uh provide support provide
uh as we have uh an extra 170 million
for
the covid winter grant scheme
and 220 million pounds for the the
holiday activities and
food programme and and we're now rolling
out
again the the national free school
meal voucher scheme it's obviously
up to schools to decide whether to have
and use lunch packs
or to or to use a voucher system
most of them use vouchers about 75 are
distributed through
uh through vouchers uh but and so we've
increased the value of vita as well
okay and we know that um school closures
potentially will reduce the attainment
gap between
disadvantaged peoples and their better
off peers by as much as 75
and that's according to a department of
education official and the education
endowment foundation we know that mental
health
problems amongst young people is on the
rise with the royal society of
pediatricians
reporting a 400 percent increase since
the first lockdown in terms of eating
disorders amongst young people
partly caused by school closures and
social isolation
so just i just want to understand what
specific assessment
is the government making of the impact
of school closures on children's
educational attainment and mental health
to inform
decision-making will schools reopen
again after the half term
and if it is clear that schools can
reopen sooner if we get teachers and
support staff up the priority list of
vaccinations
isn't this worth doing well thanks the
priority
is if we can if we can achieve what we
want to achieve with the
vaccination program the priority is
obviously to get schools openers
as soon as possible whether we can do
that
after the the half-term uh break in the
middle of february
whether we can begin to do that depends
on a number of things it depends on
uh the success of the vaccination
program it depends on
us not finding that for instance the um
the south african or
or the the brazilian uh variant uh are
immune resistant
it depends on us not finding something
else out about the disease that
uh makes us uh recalculate and i should
stress by the way
that we have no evidence of the present
to think that they these
strains are vaccine resistant very
important for the community to realize
that we have no evidencing that they are
vaccine resistant but
that's got to go that's got to go well
and then the crucial thing is that the
the overall lockdown measures have got
to continue to to work
what we're seeing today uh as i speak to
you is some
early signs of of progress
uh in uh in uh restraining the
uh the growth of the virus is some signs
of perhaps of flattening
uh of leveling off in in some parts uh
but it is far
far too early uh for us to to uh
say that this means that we can uh go
into any kind of relaxation in the
middle of february we've got to work
very very hard
uh to to achieve that and in the
meantime uh the the tragedy is for
for for so many kids that they will not
get the education
uh that they that they need uh we that's
why we desperately fought to keep
schools open uh for as long as we as we
possibly could and i know that that was
a position that was shared by many
colleagues in
uh in parliament uh we did everything we
could
and what we want to do just to answer
rob's question about about support
you know about the billion pound
catch-up fund uh we think the
way to address differential learning uh
is through
all sorts of techniques but one-to-one
uh
engagement one-to-one tutorials we think
can be very valuable
the reason why thank you problem is that
the reason i ask about that
uh about the impact assessment on it
particularly on educational
attainment because we know that um at
the institute for
fiscal studies have said that uh the
poorest students spent less time
learning
than their richer peers they've had
fewer resources at home
to learn effectively since september
pupils in areas with lower gcse
attainment and higher levels of
disadvantages more
days of school than others and we know
the overall truancy rates
almost doubled in autumn 2020. so of
course i welcome the
billion pound catch-up fund i campaigned
for it for many
months but given the extent of what is
happening and the potential damage
being done to the younger generation
what i'm trying to understand is what is
the educational route map
out of coronavirus and you talked about
a long-term plan for social care
surely we should have a long-term plan
for
education and skills as well well
we do indeed have a long-term plan both
for education and skills and
to tackle disadvantaged uh disadvantage
in schools in particular we've got
another 2.4 billion
uh that uh disadvantaged pupils are
receiving through the pupil
uh premium i i've mentioned already the
the sums that we're spending on the
the holiday activities and food
programme uh
and uh we were we are on skills
uh as you know we've got a massive uh
program a lifetime skills guarantee for
uh for everybody who's currently not
able
to access uh funding for uh for post
uh post 18 post uh 23
uh training and that it's a it's a huge
gap
in our provision uh that we're now
filling uh with
rob with lifetime skills guarantee well
it would be good to have a good
old-fashioned white paper on that topic
prime minister
on uh we just have to be sure that we're
not kicking away the uh
education a lot of opportunity for the
we've
um we're running behind the questions
and the answers have got longer
so can i urge my colleagues to our short
questions and then i can legitimately
ask the prime minister
to be brief in his answers if he answers
if his answers are too long he will just
have to stay longer
but um thank you prime minister and we
move on to catherine mckinnell
the petitions thank you um before i ask
you prime minister about childhood food
poverty and the e-petition launched by
marcus rashford
i wanted first just to ask you about one
of the most popular e-petitions
ever submitted to parliament which
called for donald trump
to be prevented from making a state
visit to the uk
in 2017 and given recent events prime
minister
do you regret saying in 2018 that donald
trump was worthy of a nobel peace prize
um i it's i'm sorry
i am in favor of the prime minister the
uk having the
best possible relationship with the
president of the united states
and i've had an excellent conversation
very recently with president-elect joe
biden
okay well on the free school meals i
know you've seen the shocking images of
half a tomato half a carrot and half a
bag of tunas part of a 10-day food
parcel
and i know you said you'll put this
right but why do children needing to eat
keep taking the government by surprise
is the prime minister not ashamed of
being schooled on feeding
hungry children by marcus rashford well
i
i i talked to marcus rashford today and
i think he's doing an excellent job of
uh of pointing these issues
out and and i i said that
uh to him i think when you look at as i
said when you look at the uh
some of these images they they don't
reflect the
the guidance uh but how it is
it is a scandal and a disgrace as i've
said that some companies
are trying to get away with the
provision that uh
they're offering and um
we've taken the steps that we've taken
that we have
and i want to i want to see the
companies that provide
these lunch packs uh doing so
properly uh and it's not it's not good
it's not good enough
uh just you know there's got to be you
can't assume that households have
uh the the supplies of uh of
of of other ingredients to to use to
make the the lunches you've got
that's that's obvious and uh
clearly the uh the packages that were
were on offer were totally woefully
inadequate and
that's why we've taken the steps that we
have i mean one of the frustrations
is the use of these private contracts
and the profits that can be made
by the middlemen when really the five
fifteen pounds
rather than five pounds worth of food
should be delivered to children
i mean the government's handed out
billions of pounds on failed covert
contracts
money for unusable face masks failed
test and trace up
covert testing kits that don't work yet
doesn't seem to trust parents enough to
give them the money directly
so that they can feed their children why
won't the why won't the government do
this
well actually is i'm sure you wouldn't
want to
inadvertently to to mislead anybody but
the it's the decision of the schools
uh to decide whether or not to uh to
have vouchers or
or lunch packs and uh clearly uh as i
said earlier on
a majority of the schools by 75 news
uh use the vouchers uh what happens is
that the schools sometimes
wish to continue to support uh their
caterers uh
the arrangements that they've they've
made they think that lunch packs are a
more
a better way of doing it and
what we've seen is some people and it's
not all of them by the way it's very
important to say is not all of them
some companies have been providing
scandalously inadequate
lunch packs and they've now agreed to
correct it and to reimburse
the schools for their failings well but
prime minister the direct payment to
parents is not
on offer for those families or for those
schools
and but isn't it time more so
that normalizing emergency food aid in
modern britain
is just deemed unacceptable and
undignified
and what is the government's strategy
for dealing with this so we don't keep
descending into crisis
well uh actually what is
not normal and what is unprecedented is
having to uh
to close schools which we very much
don't want to do
as a result of the of the pandemic and
what people have reasonably said
is that when uh kids are forced to stay
at home because schools are
closed uh then those who would normally
be in receipt of uh free school meals
should be helped and that's what we're
doing and and it's absolutely right that
we do so
prime minister i would say it's not just
about the closure of schools we have a
food poverty problem in this country and
that is what marcus rashford
is campaigning on so i would urge the
government to
publish a strategy for dealing with this
and ensuring that every child
can eat and but i wanted to just
ask one other question very quickly
about hospitality because
we have a petition in parliament at the
moment
and the hospitality industry it's a
major employer in this country
not to mention the heart and soul of
many communities and they have suffered
more than most from the covert
disruption
and given we spent two days debating in
the summer whether a scotch egg is a
substantial meal
or not and dealing with the consequences
of the ill thought out 10 pm curfew
would the prime minister agree to meet
with petitioners who believe it's time
that the government
had a dedicated minister for hospitality
to fully understand the diverse nature
of this sector
and get things right for this industry
through this crisis and beyond
well um if i may say so i think it's
very i mean i i think she's right to
to identify the the particular troubles
uh you're particularly
you're right to identify the troubles of
the hospitality sector and they've been
uh through a very very difficult time uh
we're doing everything we can to
uh to support them and uh the
uh the chancellor the business secretary
and i uh
meet regularly uh with representatives
of of that sector
uh we've given them all the uh the the
the grants the
the recent uh increasing grants that you
you know of the recent
three 000 pound uh grant specifically
for the hospitality sector
on top of the sea bills and the bounce
back loans uh the furlough scheme and
many many other
uh forms of support but uh
the best thing for the hospitality
sector is really that we all
work together to defeat the virus in the
way that i
absolutely certainly can uh with
disciplined action
and the um uh the vaccine roll out
and get them back on their feet and that
i'm sure is the best thing for them
thank you thank you okay and thank you
prime minister darren jones
thank you suburb prime minister 800 000
people have lost their jobs since
february last year and the chancellor
said it's going to get
worse why haven't you yet announced the
national jobs and skills program to
match the scale of the problem
there's been a a huge programme
announced
to a 280 billion pound
program to help people maintain their
jobs and livelihoods throughout the
pandemic
uh the uh i mentioned to to rob the the
uh lifetime skills guarantee what will
help we're doing to help people
who are moving uh darren from one you
know
catherine just mentioned the hospitality
sector uh we
it's come under huge pressure there will
be people who'll be looking for jobs
uh in other sectors uh the lifetime
skills guarantee is there to help them
the kickstart funds uh two billion pound
kicks funds are there to help uh
particularly young people and jobs jobs
jobs are
obviously our focus but the the way to
deliver uh the jobs jobs jobs agenda as
you know is jabs jabs jabs and the
the more we get the the vaccine program
the faster we can we can do it uh the
better of the employment prospects for
the whole country
thank you very much we're just going to
briefly pause our coverage of the prime
minister's appearance before the
commons liaison committee to bring you
the latest coronavirus data because we
have
significant figures this afternoon a
further 1564
people have died within 28 days of
testing positive for covid19
that figure is the highest number of uk
deaths reported
on a single day since the outbreak began
1564 people
have died in the last day with
coronavirus
that is up from a figure of 1243
yesterday in terms of the number of
cases positive cases
recorded that figure today is 47 525
up by just over 2000 from yesterday when
the figure was 45
533 let's bring in skies
melina vaselinovich who joins us from
the newsroom
and that figure in terms of the number
of deaths highest
daily figure ever recorded melania is
stark
indeed it's very alarming sarah and it's
actually the 15th
time that the number of deaths has been
above
1 000 and it is a dire situation
for the people who have suffered with
this illness and
all of their friends and family who now
mourn them
and there is no doubt that it is a
complicated complex situation across the
uk
right now there are 35 000 people
suffering with coronavirus in hospitals
now that is
70 percent more than at the peak of the
first wave
in april that's what boris johnson the
prime minister told earlier on
today mp to mps he also said that there
might be
some signs that these restrictions
may be giving some results no doubt
prompted by a slightly lower
number of cases that we've been seeing
the last two or three days but when
you're faced
with such a high death toll there's no
doubt that we're a long way away from uh
having an
exit out of this crisis right now
the prime minister also said that he
would not
count out adding some further
restrictions if the number of cases
doesn't decline climb fast enough and in
fact the london mayor sadiq khan
has today called on the prime minister
to instigate stricter restrictions uh
sadiq khan has
declared a major incident in london last
friday because of
the level of numbers of coronavirus
patients rushing
to london hospitals he has suggested
that for example places
of worship should be closed as well the
way they were
in the first lockdown as i said uh boris
johnson the prime minister said that he
would consider tougher restrictions if
they were necessary now
part of the way in the strategy to get
out of this situation
is also vaccination and we've heard from
the prime minister today that there may
be
24 7 vaccination centers on the way he
said as
soon as possible and astrazeneca the
manufacturer of the oxford vaccine said
that they would be able to scale up
production to about two million doses
per week
by mid-february but until then there's a
concerning alarming set of data that
we've had
have seen today and if you look at the
ra the r number for the uk
that is the number of people that one
infected person
passes the virus onto now that's between
1 and 1.4
and that means that for now the outbreak
is still growing exponentially sarah
okay uh malaya vasalinovic thanks very
much
indeed i'm just looking at some more
figures coming into us
on vaccinations and uh
let me see if i can get that figure at
the total in the last
24 hour period there were 47
525 new infections at 1
564 deaths are recorded of people who
have been who have died within 28 days
of a positive test and that bringing the
total number of people who've
died with covert 19 to 84 767
in terms of that vaccine figure that i
was mentioning three million
vaccines have been administered so far
in the uk
2.6 million of those are first
doses let's return now to the commons
liaison committee boris johnson
answering questions from the chairs of
the common select committee
i'll study it uh but uh on
on your point stephen about the about uc
um
uh i i i take your point i think that
that what we want to see is a jobs
uh we want to see people in employment
we want to see the economy bouncing back
and i think
most people in this country would rather
see a focus on
jobs and growth in wages than uh
focusing on
on welfare but clearly we have to keep
all these things under review
even with that increase in universal
credit there has been a huge surge
of food bank demand in the pandemic
do you agree that we ought to be seeing
that reversed
well i i think that people who uh who
help with food banks and
uh set up foodbanks doing a wonderful
job and and
i thank them i thank them for it and
yeah in an ideal world
uh we would be uh people would uh
be able to have absolute confidence in
getting in in getting what they need
from there
from their weekly shop and that's why
we're focusing so much on
things like the living wage uh
increasing
uh uh pay wherever wherever we can
increases in pay for a million uh key
workers uh this year
uh and doing everything that we can for
the
for the poorest needs and don't forget
that of the 280 billion pounds that have
been spent
since the pandemic began on supporting
the
uh jobs and livelihoods uh the
uh the benefit has gone
uh uh overwhelmingly to the to the
poorest and neediest groups
well uh there are a lot of people still
claiming the old style benefits job
seekers about
employment and support allowance their
circumstances are identical to people
claiming universal credit the legacy
benefit rates were always the same
as the uc rates but they weren't
increased by
20 pounds a week what justification is
there for
paying them 20 pounds a week less
well we we want everybody to to move on
to universal credit we think it's a
successful
uh system and i i
note with some anxiety that it's still
the stated policy of the labour party to
to abolish universal credit i don't
think that's the the right way forward
well if you take people for example with
severe disability they're not allowed to
claim
universal credit and yet their benefit
hasn't been uploaded in line with
uh universal credit surely it should be
and and
if the question about universal credit
is resolved at the time of the budget
will the question of those legacy
benefit rates be addressed as well
at the same time we will we will we're
committed to
uh doing everything we can to address
uh the the needs of uh of those on on
welfare
uh we believe strongly in uh in in
in universal credit it's it's it's
helping uh
it's putting more money into pockets of
families across the country we're
particularly with a 1000 pound increase
but the best thing is
is to get people into employment and and
that's that's what we're working for
can i raise one final area we spoke at
the liaison
committee in may about hard-working
law-abiding
families with no recourse to public
funds and you made a point which i very
much agreed with that i quote
you said people who've worked hard for
this country who live and work here
should have support of one kind or
another
i think that's absolutely right but
unfortunately that isn't
the current policy and it's in my area
it's one of the
factors in the spread of the pandemic
people can't stop working because
they they can't claim social security so
they have to carry on
working shouldn't this nrpf condition at
least be suspended for the duration of
the pandemic
uh the i i totally understand the
the logic of your of your of your
argument but
the the the problem is that it's a very
very long-standing
uh provision in this country that that
nrpf
uh conditions um
uh should not have should uh
uh should apply uh for those
for instance who are here uh illegally
or
uh or unlawfully and uh i don't i think
that
it would be it would be not the right
way forward to
uh to to change that um there are there
and then just and what i think we also
discussed steam was
um just just because uh
people have um uh their nrpf
it doesn't mean that they they're not
eligible
for uh for for uh
support of many kinds uh and provided
through local councils or
or otherwise no but they're not able to
claim universal
credit and and that's right many people
to
to to carry on working and i just i i in
the current arrangements go recently
2012
we've seen the education department's
been helpful giving people
access to free school meals the housing
department has accommodated
rough sleepers with no of course
property funds at public expense but
it's not the home office
still in a kind of windrush mindset
which
isn't picking up your point about people
ought to get support
well i i think that's i i don't i don't
i don't agree with that and just to get
to go back to the point i was making
earlier
nrpf uh people i have
massive sympathy for them uh but they
they they do
have access to uh the
current advice to a potential team to to
furlough um
to uh funds that the local authorities
can
uh make available to help people in
particular hardship
uh 7.2 billion pounds of funding we've
made available to local authorities
so there there this country does not
allow people
uh to to fall through the cracks even if
they are
classified as nrpf the point you make
about uc is a valid one
but i think i've given what i hope
intelligible reasons for why we want to
make a distinction between
those who are eligible for for uc and
those who are nrpf thank you stephen we
must move on
uh caroline knox
thank you prime minister specifically
for making domestic abuse
uh so central to your broadcast last
week was really welcomed by the sector
but can i just ask what additional
protections have been put in place to
help victims of domestic abuse
who have insecure immigration status
well the since the pandemic began
we've uh done what we can to encourage
people who are the victims of of
domestic abuse to
to come forward we set up special
helplines we've
been investing as you know caroline in
independent domestic violence advisors
but but also uh it's a uh a conditioner
although
the the lockdown rules are very strict
uh as you know
uh people they don't apply to uh victims
of
of domestic abuse because we don't think
we should
stop people from seeking the help that
they need
indeed they don't but is there any
specific policies for
victims who might be here on a tier 4 or
5 visa or who might be entirely
dependent upon their spouse's status
what specific programs have been put in
place to provide them with the support
they need
well they would be they would be they're
the normal
support that any victim of domestic
abuse
has in this country and we don't
tolerate domestic abuse and
we want those who are responsible for it
to be
to be found out and and punished
uh there are some who have fallen
through the cracks and you just said you
didn't want
anyone to fall through the cracks can i
ask you about another group of people
who've fallen through the cracks
namely those reliant on british sign
language for
their uh interpretation of the coded
lockdown rules
those who might have learning
difficulties uh can i ask
when the home secretary says that the
current lockdown rules are clear
and the commissioner of the metropolitan
police says that it's preposterous that
anyone
could be unaware of the rules why are we
still not doing a better job of
explaining to vulnerable people
what those rules are well caroline thank
you
if i may i'm gonna i've now been asked
this a couple of times about
uh sign language in in particular i'm
i'm i'm
i i there are obviously various
logistical
uh issues that need to be overcome but
i'm going to take that away
and and see what we can do uh to uh
to increase uh sign language but
what i can tell you is that um
the campaigns that we that we so the
normal uh tv broadcast for instance
uh but the the campaigns that we have
uh are available and accessible in
uh are provided in accessible formats
and uh and
uh and and translations and uh
we have multiple media channels uh
that we use uh uh to help
reach people um the the stay-at-home
poster for instance was produced with a
voice-over
and british sign language uh
interpretation
the prime minister did you could write
to us on that subject
very happy to do very happy to do so yes
on the 12th of october you said there
hadn't been enough time to get a bsl
interpreter for the broadcast then
there wasn't enough time clearly last
week and today you're still taking it
away
i think it's absolutely shameful that we
haven't done better on this when both
the welsh and scottish governments
have i wanted to ask about access to
healthcare during the pandemic
we know that more men than women have
been impacted by covid
but the evidence shows that it's women
who are finding access
to specific services difficult i was
contacted by a constituent yesterday who
was told that her surgery is not
currently doing
smear tests what is your response
to her when she says how long is it
acceptable for her to have to wait
to get her smear test well i i
obviously i sympathize very much with
anybody who's
had any service or treatment in the nhs
delayed as a result of
the pressure on the on the nhs and
sadly that's what we are seeing uh we're
seeing delays in
uh in cancer we're seeing delays in uh
in smear tests and vital services
that people need and that's a as a
result of the increase in
the numbers of uh of covid patients
and that's why we've got to to work flat
out to
get the the virus under control and
reduce the
the current wave and and and give people
the service
that we need and i what i would say to
your constituents i'm very sorry for the
delay that she's
uh she's experiencing
women especially
disproportionately employed in insecure
and low paid work
what specific parts of the kickstart
scheme or the apprenticeship scheme
is the government considering to put
aside for bame people and indeed for
women
who have been disproportionately
affected economically by the pandemic
i can't give you a a specific proportion
account can i just on employment
ask a question back in november you made
a pledge to make sure that there were
more
women in parliament is the house of
lords
included in parliament in your view and
why have we not seen
appointments for lords increase the
number of women where of course you
could make a direct difference
we believe it very much in uh increasing
the numbers of
women in every part of our
parliament i'm thrilled that i
that we now i think have more female
pps's for instance than
the male pps's and the numbers
grow steadily part the parliament is
unrecognizable uh from
uh what it was like when uh i was
elected alone from when
uh bernard was elected which wasn't
actually that much uh earlier
and uh and long may that change
uh continue and and accelerate and you
know you ask about
the uh the impact of women on on covid
or the impact of covidon women i'd just
like to point out that in fighting
uh kovid we've had uh
spectacular female leadership uh from
kate bingham of the vaccine
task force uh from uh dido harding of
nhs
test and trace uh and many others
women in the lords in fact prime
minister
where you have failed to put 50
women in in either of the two
appointment rounds you had
well uh you you're pointing out a very
uh important
uh statistic and we'll we'll do what we
can uh
to address it but uh uh
it it's not something that's been so far
drawn to my attention but thank you for
doing so
the 50 50 campaign is rather close to my
heart as you understand prime minister
that we get more women into parliament
um and
moving to the home affairs select
committee chair
a prominent woman in parliament uh
yvette cooper
thank you joe thank you prime minister
it's nearly four weeks since we were
warned about
the south africa variant but if i still
wanted to travel from south africa
here today i could get a flight via
dubai or istanbul
with no test before i left no test
during no test on arrival
go straight onto the tube from heathrow
and then onto a train and travel home
across the country
you said tough measures were being
brought in to protect the country
but why on earth have you allowed this
to happen legally
the last four weeks sorry do you say
illegally
legally legally all of this could happen
legally but get that flight
not be tested and arrive in the country
and go on to public transport
why is that allowed well uh the
the reason that uh we've um
wanted to to have a balanced approach in
our in our border policies obviously
you need to uh make sure that you're
balancing the
the threat to uh to health with the
threat to the
uh to the economy uh but passengers from
all international destinations are now
going to have to produce a
negative test result before they arrive
in uh in england
and uh of course uh we've gone further
and provided uh additional protection uh
for those coming from south africa i
will look at the point that you make
about the route that you
uh that you describe we know that direct
flights aren't enough in the first
wave there was only one percent of the
cases into the country came from
china 63 percent came from
france or spain and the pre-travel tests
that the prime minister referred to
that you referred to prime minister are
very welcome but
other countries brought them in months
ago
we're not bringing them in until friday
why did you not bring them in
in november when other countries did
well
sorry we've had uh uh
a measures at the uh the border
uh since the eighth of june last year
and
uh actually 3.5 million passengers have
been spot checked
and in last seven days alone uh 30
percent of all
arriving passengers have been checked
and uh there is a great deal of effort
that goes into
uh checking the passenger locator forms
uh
the uh that um people are obliged to
fill in
well we heard this morning prime
minister that those
forms are just checked simply to see if
people have
filled them in we also heard from border
force
that the only that 90 percent of cases
were not being
checked and we heard there was even less
follow-up
when people then return across the
country having traveled
by public transport so you've been
repeatedly warned
about the weaknesses in the quarantine
system a system that we heard
experts describe this morning as it
might as well be voluntary because so
few checks are taking place
why haven't you strengthened that system
well we have uh with respect straight
strength in that system and
passengers arriving from all
international locations are required to
present
a negative test before arriving in
england
well they will be from friday but once
again
you could have introduced that testing
system from thursday you could also have
in place
testing again on arrival rather than
simply 72 hours beforehand
you could have stronger quarantine and
stronger checks
like very many other countries do
let me press you on the brazil issue
we were warned about the brazil variant
three days ago
we don't know yet whether that could
potentially
undermine the vaccination program so why
aren't you taking
immediate action on a precautionary
basis
we are and we're putting in extra
measures to
ensure that people coming from brazil
are checked and started indeed stopping
people coming
from brazil so
are you that's been a new announcement
you just told jeremy hunt earlier on
in this evidence session that you were
still looking at this
when are you going to bring those
measures sorry i said
i said what we were looking at was the
question of whether or not the
brazilian variant was immune resistant
so has a new travel ban been announced
on
flights from brazil well uh we are
taking steps to ensure that we do not
see the import of
uh this new variant from brazil
but with respect prime minister what are
those
steps because as of a few hours ago i
understood that
it was still possible to get direct
flights from brazil
and also without any testing in place as
of today wednesday
three days after we've heard about the
brazil variant nearly four
weeks after the third campus to arrive
without any testing
in place no we're we're taking steps to
stop the brazil
variant being imported into these
countries we've taken steps to stop the
south african
variant from being imported into this
country as in indeed the french took
steps to
to stop the uh the kent variant being
imported into
into france and and that's what
countries do
but the promise that we know that the
french system is in place we know that
you have to have
pcr tests before you arrive in france as
of today
four weeks after we move out of the
south africa variant
no test is required to enter the uk and
it won't be
until friday as of today you can't tell
me any additional measures that we've
put in place you just keep using the
words
we're putting in place stronger measures
but please tell me what they actually
are i would be very reassured to hear
what they actually are
well you have to you'll have to show uh
from all countries that you've got a
negative test in order to come to this
country
okay that's not until friday it's still
months later than other countries
have done so in fact so we
warned about the border measures sorry
we had
from june we had a mandatory 10-day
quarantine
for people coming from countries not on
the approved
travel corridor list as you know
but prime minister as we heard in the
home affairs select committee
this morning that quarantine system that
you introduced
in june is so much weaker than other
countries
people can still go directly onto public
transport
uh 90 of cases are not checked to even
see if they have filled in the forms
and there is very little further
follow-up so that quarantine system we
heard this morning is simply
not working the problem prime minister
is this reward in the spring
about the need for the measures delayed
then you were warned
again now and we've still got delays in
getting the kinds of border measures in
place we still haven't put the system
sorted on south africa
and on a brazil variant and this is on
top of the delays in dealing with
lockdowns
schools and so on you give the
impression each time
that you just delay all of the difficult
and uncomfortable decisions until the
last possible minute
and when so many lives are at stake
prime minister is this
really the leadership that we need well
uh
if if i may say so this country has uh
led
the uh the world and indeed the the
whole of europe
in uh rolling out a vaccine and uh one
of the things that
you don't often hear from uh
commentators on your side of the
uh political divide is that that is the
case
and i i disagree strongly with what you
said about the protections we have at uk
borders we're conducting huge quantities
of checks we have we insist on
people going into quarantine when they
arrive from long travel corridor
uh areas uh we're putting in measures to
uh protect this country both against the
south african variant the
uh the brazilian uh variant will
continue to
to be very tough indeed at the moment uh
we have a
a pandemic that is being driven by
uh in large part by a new variant that
seems to have originated
uh though obviously we can't be sure uh
that seems to have
originated in a mutation or several
mutations
uh in in this country and uh we're doing
everything we can
to bear down on that but uh if you look
at
uh the achievement of this country in uh
in in fighting the uh the vaccine i
don't think you should neglect
the the rollout of the uh of fighting
the virus i think you should run out the
the speed of the of the vaccine program
so far
please please look again at the border
measures thank you chad
thank you uh miss cooper and we're we're
well behind now i'm afraid but that was
um long questions and long answers so
hillary ben
as quickly as we can please thank you
very much
uh mr chairman moving on to the section
about uh
britain's place in the world post brexit
um in december 2019 prime minister you
said that there was no
question of there being checks on goods
going from great britain
to northern ireland do you remember
saying that
i do and indeed uh thanks to the deal
that we have
there is a their trade is flowing
so smoothly as i said in answer to an
earlier question between
uh great britain and northern ireland
that it is now the preferred route
of julia's um
well if it's going so smoothly prime
minister
why have we seen some empty shelves
in supermarkets in northern ireland why
has the northern ireland
agriculture minister warned that a range
of frozen and chilled foods could be
unavailable after the temporary grace
period ends and why did the
big supermarkets right to the chancellor
of the duchy of lancaster
this week to call for urgent
intervention to prevent further
disruption if it's all going so well
well the uh if if you listen to what the
the supermarket's actually saying today
i believe that uh
andrew opie of the uh of the
the the retail uh association
uh said that supply was pretty much back
to normal
for supermarkets in northern ireland
but what the supermarkets have warned
about is
what may happen if the grace period
let's take the three-month grace period
that ends at the end of march
during which they don't have to provide
export health certificates for
all of the food and agri-food products
that they're
transporting into northern ireland their
warning about what happens if that is
not extended now you can
give us a simple reassurance if that's
possible today
can you guarantee both those
supermarkets and shoppers in northern
ireland
that the grace period will be extended
after the end of march uh what i can
certainly
guarantee is that uh if there are
serious problems in in victorian or
supplying
uh supermarkets in northern ireland uh
because of
some piece of uh bureaucracy that's uh
misapplied then uh we will we will
simply exercise article 16 of the
protocol because it's absurd
uh that there should be such uh
difficulties and
uh that we will make sure that uh
supplies continue
uh if uh it just goes without saying
that
any difficulties that uh that remain uh
will naturally fall away
anyway because the uh the people of
northern ireland
have to vote to uh to retain uh the
protocol
in four years time well it
promised it's not misapplied bureaucracy
it is the very essence of the northern
ireland protocol which you
negotiated turning to something else you
said many times
you've referred to the uk gaining
control of our waters
why is it that some of the scottish
fishing fleet is currently tied up
rather than out fishing well i i
i understand very much the uh the
frustrations of
of uh people who are fishing
uh community and scottish uh
fishermen and women who are facing
what i believe are temporary
frustrations in so far as there are
delays caused by
uh a variety of of problems
uh we will compensate uh
those uh those fishing businesses
um but there is a massive opportunity
for those
uh for that for scotland and for the
whole of the uk
uh with the increase in quota that we
get from the
from the deal 25 percent uh by uh before
the end of
the end of the transition period
hundreds of thousands of tons
more fish and uh the ability to
fish all the fish in scottish waters uh
from
uh the end of that period so are you
telling us today that you think those
difficulties um
because they can't get their product to
market in time are only temporary
oh yes that's what you're saying i
believe that's right yes
you do right but isn't it the case that
red tape cost and bureaucracy was the
inevitable consequence
of the trade agreement that you've
negotiated
with the eu one freight expert has
described a mountain of red tape
brought in on the first of january isn't
that the consequence
of leaving the single market in the
customs unit this is just a fact is it
not
that i may say so mr ben that's not
that's not compatible with
uh the the the what we are we're seeing
uh with the um the volumes of traffic
at the at the moment uh from uh from gb
to
to ni and as i say i think one of the
extraordinary things about the first of
january was that it did not produce the
disruption that people uh claim that it
would
i i don't doubt that there will be
problems and businesses must prepare for
for change things will be uh things will
be different and you have to get the
right
forms you have to be conscious of the of
the certificates that you
uh that you need but i believe that all
that is
uh readily can be readily done
and overall as i say the traffic at the
moment is smooth and
there are as far as i know no cues and
we will address
all issues as fast as we can
thank you just one final very brief
question is it true that the
uk rejected an offer from the european
union during the negotiations
for a 90-day visa-free period
for uk musicians who wanted to go and
tour in europe
no that's that's not true uh my
understanding is that
it wasn't uh no
we we wanted to have uh reciprocal
rights for
uh for musicians to tour but before uh
everybody worries about this i should
just stress that
uh what we what we have is the right for
uh for uk
music musicians to go and play uh in
other uh
european countries in eu countries uh
for for 90 out of 180 days
thank you and thank you mr ben admirably
brief
both of you uh pete was shot
we can't hear pete we're shot
you need to unmute
need to unmute pete we can't hear you
well can i start i think and i know of
agreement and i'm
pretty sure that you and i prime
minister are both democrats
and we both believe that in a
parliamentary democracy
a majority should be respected so
therefore can you
tell me if a majority of the scottish
people
want their country to be an independent
nation
how do they democratically achieve that
objective
well pete let me let me tell you that uh
what i think that they should
do is hold a a referendum such as the
one that was held in 2014
and when they say that uh to the people
of
of that country and indeed all of the uk
that that's a once in a generation
event uh which is what they said uh that
they should
in a democratic spirit uh honor uh that
pledge
well can we impact just a couple of
these things because again that's just
an utter load of rubbish there was
nothing in any legal text about once in
the generation there's two legal pets
the end of it everywhere in payment in
the smith commission there is no
mention whatsoever right once in a
generation
and if you want to use rhetorical
flourishing prime minister
i think that you said it was a brexit
extension you would be dead in a ditch
well
you're sitting in front of us and that
ditch is still unoccupied
so surely once again if the scottish
people
want to achieve independence how is that
democratically achieved
what's the answer i i give uh pete with
great respect i've given you i've given
you my answer
as far as i can see the uh the brexit
extension has
has has come and gone uh we're out of
the eu scottish
fishermen uh fishing businesses have
access uh
to unparalleled marine wealth in the
course of the next few years
i hope they exploit it i hope that the
snp
isn't so deranged as to hand back
control of our fisheries
uh to the eu and i remember distinctly
uh alex salmond and nicolas sturgeon
saying that it was a once in a
generation
event but did you not hear them say that
i've been that
just started it's not many legal texts
but once an intimidation did you say
that
could you not answer this question is
are you seriously saying
that democracy in scotland doesn't
matter and a majority should be
inspected
i could always think of one other sort
of world leader that would deny
democracy like that and he's currently
sitting in the white house
are you seriously saying to scottish
people their democracy doesn't count and
do ignore it
i i i i think you know you need to to
ask yourself whether you're seriously
saying that
right now in the middle of a pandemic uh
whether the people of scotland or all of
the uk
or anywhere uh think it's sensible to
have a a referendum on another
constitution on a constitutional issue
uh when we're trying to uh as we've
discussed earlier
uh to get the pandemic uh down
to generate millions of jobs that we're
going to need over the next
few years to allow this whole country uh
to bounce back
uh together i think that's what the
people of this country want to focus on
i think it's incredible
that the scottish national party is is
is focusing on
uh on a referendum when you can't say by
the way
uh what you want this referendum to uh
to discuss
uh do you know you can't say what uh the
the
the prospectus is uh for the destruction
of the united kingdom do you want to
scrap the army scrap the pan scrap the
crap screen scrap the bomb what is it uh
what is that what
you can't say you can't say what your
agenda is all you can say
is that you want to break up uh the uk
in some way and i think that the people
of this country
i think the people in this country want
to focus on fighting covid
and getting on with building back better
together
i've got a very elegant solution for
that prime minister let's have a
referendum not now but it's a pandemic
that is first part of our next
parliamentary scripture
let's have a referendum look at that
case to describe people we'll pick the
case why we believe that scotland should
be an independent nation
and let the people decide that's what
the scottish people want there are
17 opinion posts now showing that a
majority in scotland want an
independence referendum
you know prime minister i know everybody
watching this
knows that a referendum is coming
quiet just get on with it why don't we
have this referendum
let the scottish people choose if you're
global brexit britain so wonderful
they'll vote for that
if they agree with us that we should be
independent why can't we just get on and
do it
well because because we had a referendum
uh on the issue
in 2014 uh which uh senior members of
your party perhaps not you
you uh said was a once in a generation
event it was on that basis
uh the people voted uh in the way that
they did very substantially to keep our
wonderful union
uh together and if you look at the and i
think people want to focus on
on fighting the pandemic and i think by
the way one of the one of the weirdest
things i've heard in the last
couple of days is that uh the
the scottish nationalist party is is so
uh averse
to any uh scottish national party he's
so averse
about that is so is so averse to uh
anything that comes from england that
i'm told you won't even use the word
oxford
uh oxford vaccine uh perhaps you perhaps
you'd like to say something in favor of
the oxford vaccine
what i'll say to you prime minister your
response to these questions
just demonstrate the pitiful state that
the scottish conservatives are
understood
you're prepared to deny it once you you
mentioned
about oxford vaccines what the scottish
people want as a say in the future
they're hearing you
saying that you're not prepared to give
that i i don't even
bother know why you're bothering
standing in the next scottish election
surely you know
continuing to say no to scotland is
unsustainable and there will be
another referendum i think what people i
what people
in this country across this country want
in scotland and elsewhere is for us to
focus
on their needs and from where i sit i
see the scottish national party
and whether you're a nationalist or not
it's manifest for
for you i would say by any definition of
that word you you were
they you see them failing on crime
failure on education
uh failure on tax and with nothing to
say
except that you want to break up the
united kingdom that's
all you've got to say and what you won't
say is what the purpose of the
referendum
is you won't say whether you want to
keep the pound
uh whether what will happen to pensions
you won't say what will happen to
the diplomatic service the security
services
the military uh the monarchy you won't
say anything about it all you will say
is that you want a referendum and you
and uh you had one
in 2014 and the result uh was decisive
as you as i think
as as i think snp leaders said in 2014.
let's have that referendum and let the
scottish people want to be an
independent nation let them decide
i think you've got to explain what you
mean by that thank you
it's quite simple prime minister last
question
for the union we've got a proposition
for independence well that the scottish
people
choosing to say whatever outcome they
decide is what will happen
it's very straightforward you did it
with brexit if you can have your
democracy in brexit why can the scottish
people not have their democracy what
about their constitutional future
anyway i i don't think that that's the i
think what people want to focus on now
is uh addressing this pandemic i think
that uh the last thing this country
needs
is to wrap itself into years of
constitutional wrangling
on a prospectus that from that account
was very very unclear
um moving on uh northern ireland
committee chair simon hall
thank you uh chairman good afternoon
prime minister there was
huge relief when the protocol was
uh agreed and signed off um
talk of invoking uh article
16 but i'd suggest be avoided at all
cost
uh it would do huge damage to the good
friday agreement as you're aware
and also give damage to the relationship
between
our country and the united states
but it does seem to us and certainly
evidence that we've taken in the
committee
that there needs to be a significant
piece of work
across agencies of government including
but not
ex in totality the northern ireland
office the northern ireland executive
treasury hmrc deferra bay's cabinet
office
dft and the republic in order to make
sure that exporters
to northern ireland know the rules
because they want to conform to them
i think you're right to say that trade
is starting to get back to a certain
degree of normalcy
but we need a huge education campaign
amongst gb
based businesses so that they know what
it is they need to do
both in the grace period and afterwards
so what assurance can you
give us that the joint committee is
going to use the grace period
between now and the 31st of march in
order to ensure that all of the creases
are ironed out rather than having a
cliff edge
at the end of march where we see some of
the current
disruption continuing unnecessarily
well thanks very much simon and uh
thanks what you've you've said about the
the operation of the
of the protocol i think as i said to an
earlier question it's it's
inevitable that there's going to be uh
teething problems when you have a change
as substantial as the one
that we we've just had the uk now
controls its borders it's its laws
uh we can do free trade deals around the
world we control our our waters
uh we have uh substantial sums of
of cash that we now have available that
we didn't have before
and we need to get on and uh and and
make the most of it we've also got to
make sure that
we minimize the impacts on on business
and
so uh the trader support service uh is
going to be
uh is going to be ramped up and i'm told
that
uh since the 1st of january uh 95
of the uh of the of the
online declarations that you have to uh
have to have to make her
are done within 15 completed and
processed
within 15 minutes and as i say the
the the volumes uh remain
significantly higher going gb ni
than on gb island routes that may change
as uh as we go forward and uh further
pressures emerge
uh but we'll do our best to to iron them
all out
thank you i mean certainly our
understanding is that capacity at the
ports both gb and northern ireland
uh is sufficient uh that there is plenty
of capacity and infrastructure there it
is just this
lack of confidence if you will between
british businesses exporting to the uk
to ni which is leading a lot of people
to say well we won't bother we want to
see greater
uh clarity and that does need to be
addressed very quickly so i just hope
that the
joint committee will very proactively
and energetically pull together all of
those agencies of government
to make sure that our exporters have got
the best opportunity because the risk
has to be does it not
uh the producers in the republic
will say let's trade north south far
more
and that would be a disadvantage to gb
based business
completely right and that's why it's so
important for instance that
we sort out the business of chilled
meats and the the great british banger
gets through uh in the way that it uh it
should and
and will uh all these all these problems
individually uh are uh i believe capable
of
of of speedy resolution
thank you um can i can i take you back
to your previous
uh department at the uh at the foreign
office and you'll be aware
of the fco commissioned uh report by
william
shaw cross into
qadhafi enabled ira terrorism
um william shaw cross has submitted his
report to the foreign office
many many months ago and silence
has been the response from the fco there
are continuing talks
within the united nations of um
campaigns to defrost if you will frozen
libyan
assets some of which are held in the uk
can you
ask the foreign secretary to get a wig
along if you will
to publish the shaw cross report and set
out how the government is going to
respond
to this very important issue which is
dragged on i'm sure you'll agree for far
too long
well i'm very grateful to william shaw
cross for what he's done
and uh the effort that he's gone to
uh in solving a very very difficult
problem this is the
the the potential for compensation
uh from libyan funds for victims of ira
uh terrorism who uh were uh
who uh whose injuries or or who who were
killed
as a result of uh semtex or other
uh weapons supplied by libya uh
the the difficult there are many many
great difficulties with trying to get a
a satisfactory uh solution it's it's
it's proved extremely difficult
to uh draw the uh the right
uh net or or to to decide exactly who
might be
uh by it might be eligible uh for these
uh these funds uh and there's a great
deal of controversy
uh surrounding that uh it's also
extremely difficult to uh
find a way uh in the given the current
precarious situation in libya
of uh of extracting the funds and
uh as i i can see my uh jeremy
my successor uh will know very well that
libya
as foreign secretary will know very well
that uh
libya is basically uh
totally a divided state at the at the
moment there are some uh
fate signs of of progress but until we
have
a government that we can really work
with in libya it's difficult to uh to
make progress on
unfreezing assets or any of the other uh
things that you describe
so um william shaw cross's work is
is is by name is is is is valuable
uh i think it's very very important it's
particularly important for uh people
families in in northern ireland uh but
we're we are i'm afraid some way off
having the result that
uh that we might hope for and i've got
to be honest with you simon
i i'm it will be very very tough uh to
get
any kind of equitable solution out of
this
out of this disaster other countries
many years ago particularly united
states
were able to get compensation for the
for victims of libyan terrorism in the
way that the british state
uh did not uh we've been trying to
rectify what i think was an omission
uh it's proving extremely difficult
thank you mr hawk
thank you um prime minister we're we're
pushing
past five o'clock um we would be
extremely grateful if you could give us
a little bit more time very happy to do
so
for william cash tom hugh tugging and
philip dunn on some quick fire questions
at the end
uh sir william cash uh good afternoon
prime minister
um just to start off with
um you led us through the last year from
early december last year
from parliamentary paralysis into
a position in which we not only had a
general election
which had a massive majority for the
conservative party but also
to take us out of eu jurisdiction and
the european court of justice
and reasserting our sovereignty in a
very
important and vital way for the future
of this country
um we heard today both in prime
minister's questions and also
in the um urgent question that was put
to the chancellor of the dutch of
lancaster
uh a lot of discussion quite
understandably
regarding the question of the northern
ireland protocol
it is an immensely important issue but i
think you
have already indicated that there are
some challenges and then they are being
met
uh what andrew opis said today um and
what
in fact the director of the cbi in
northern ireland said on the today
program this morning
all indicated that although there are
challenges and there are some
difficulties in relation to all these
questions in northern ireland the
protocol
that actually given the fact that we're
in the process of covid
there are a number of very significant
uh responses to those challenges going
on could you enlarge on that a bit so
that
people can get a better idea as to
for example how we're going to improve
the transparency in the joint committee
which of course is primarily the
responsibility of the
chancellor the dutch of lancaster
because in the european spiritual
committee we're working flat out on all
these things
and we just want to be quite sure not
only that we're going to meet the
challenges
but we're also going to have the
transparency within that committee
to make sure that we can ask the right
questions and get the right answers
thanks very much bill and thanks for
everything that
that you've done to make uh this
possible i think that the situation
uh in uh in gbnei trade uh as i was
discussing just now with simon is
is far better than some people have
perhaps expected
uh this things are much smoother there
are some problems and
in in an interest of transparency uh
second the sales of second-hand
uh vehicles we've sorted that out now
with a compensation scheme
uh for uh for second-hand uh cars in uh
sold in northern ireland so they don't
pay
additional uh v80 so we've solved that
one we've got one on seed potatoes
as opposed to where potatoes and as you
know there's a there's a
there are sanitary and phyto-sanctuary
issues about the export of seed potatoes
from this country to
uh to the eu we're solving that though
uh the export of seed potatoes is very
very small
uh in there from the the uk to the
uh eu i think we export as many uh to to
the whole of
uh the eu as we export to egypt in terms
of
seed potatoes uh there are uh there's
the the question of
pet passports but we have a i believe a
way of
of solving that there's the uh the the
chilled meats issue that i've already
referred to and one or two others
they are they are by and large uh small
soluble uh questions uh which one by one
uh we are we are addressing and the
uh mauro cephkovic and uh the chancellor
of lancaster i think have done a
fantastic job
in the joint committee of addressing
them and building that confidence in
trade
uh nigb gb uh ni
it's it's it's incredibly light touch uh
insofar as we have to do
uh any checks at all and it is and it is
working
well the key point is in so far if
if there are further problems that uh
really
uh or with the eu or our partners insist
on
an interpretation of the protocol that
we we think is
unfair or unnecessary then article 16 of
course
exists to uh to address that and
uh the whole thing falls away
unless the people of northern ireland
actually vote to
continue with with the arrangements so
i see in the meantime northern ireland
is part of the uk customs territory does
free trade deals
uh with us around the world and there is
unfettered access
for ni goods uh to gb and
uh for gb uh to to ni with the very
small
uh caveats that i've entered and where
and we are
working now to to reduce them the whole
time so
i'm i i believe that businesses uh
both north and south of the border and
ireland but also businesses east-west
can be full of confidence about the
future i think northern ireland
has a massive opportunity to exploit uh
its
uh the advantages it has
thank you very much and if i might just
finish my point by saying
uh that there are obviously some
challenges the
johnson dutch and lancaster made that
clear this morning you said it in prime
minister's questions you've said it
again now
and i don't think i have anything
further to add at this stage because
we're running short of time and uh i
think the chairman
probably were quite glad if we could
move on to the next person
yeah well thank you thank you brian yes
i i i gave a long answer about seed
potatoes
there are a few other issues but we will
fix them and hopefully they can be fixed
through the joint committee rather than
resorting to article
16. yes that's the last resort um thank
you
uh now the chairman of the foreign
affairs for committee tom chugginhard
thank you very much prime minister
philip dunn will no doubt cover cop26 so
leaving the environment aside
what are your priorities for the g7 that
we're hosting this year
uh building back better together
and if you if you look at the uh the
pandemic
i think that uh it caught the
international system totally
unprepared in all sorts of of ways and
uh we need to work together on uh
preparing for pandemics in the
in the future uh uh discussing uh
yvette and i were talking about borders
and quarantine
there is no international consensus
about uh how this should operate it was
a
complete everybody took a different
approach
there's no international consensus about
um
uh how to dis dispense vaccines
uh there there are no agreements about
some of the
uh about about lockdown measures about
the
about ppe uh the global system
uh basically failed to to match the
the demands of the time and it was a
kind of cert it was a keeper
environment so so we want to build back
we want to work together and one of the
things we're looking at is
is the is the possibility of a of a of a
treaty
on on pandemics uh working together to
create
jobs jobs jobs uh for our uh for our
electorates across the the whole of the
uh of the g7 area uh that will be
uh one of the key focus and and and
global free trade will clearly be
important
thinking about china uh will be
important in how we as g7
uh respond to the uh the challenges
posed by uh by china
and many other issues can i push you on
uh the china element you've spoken in
the past that your mattress will monitor
your nightmares given how much data is
flowing east
and the fact that the polyp bureau of uh
in beijing
has updated ricardo and smith by adding
data
to one of the factors of production will
you commit to putting
privacy on the agenda of the g7 to
protect britain
british people from intrusions into
their privacy yes
look i i want to stress that um when i
talk about the
the the challenges of uh of china
it's important that we um and i know you
you you lead the the the the china
research group in
uh in in parliament and we should be
vigilant we should
i think that uh dom rob gave a terrific
speech
about the uh about the uyghurs and the
and what's happening
there and i think the policy there is is
completely right but
i i don't want us to and i think we've
got to be very vigilant about
uh what's happening with our critical
national infrastructure and
and uh and about the protection of our
of our data and our cyber space and
and we we are we're we're taking more
measures to do that
but i don't want this country or this uh
or this government to lurch into a
position of
of sort of unthinking uh cynophobia i
don't believe that be right for
uh for the uk i think that i think that
there's a balance to be struck
i think everybody supports you on that
but you'll remember that just after the
war
our country was one of many that set up
the general agreement on tariffs and
trade to resist the soft encroachment of
common term the soviet bloc
would you commit to looking to create a
general agreement
on data for democracies to share uh
the ability to harvest large amounts of
data and work with it but in a way that
uh respects the privacy and freedoms of
free peoples
yeah we're looking at uh all that kind
of thing particularly on
on data not just in the context of the
g7 but also
of the of the of the d10 uh
so the the so if you add the uh
australia
uh india south korea to the to the g7
you have the the the some of the major
democratic countries of the of the world
coming together and
uh issues about privacy and data are
certainly ones that we watched
we want to explore together as well as
technological issues
prime minister you've uh you've
demonstrated the use of social media in
the uk quite effectively
are you comfortable with the fact that a
u.s company controls how you communicate
with your electorate or do you think
the media rules that affect ownership of
newspapers and tv stations should also
affect
your ability to communicate with your
three million followers
i do think there's a real debate now to
be had
about the status of the internet the big
internet
uh companies um uh
whether they should be identified as uh
as mere platforms
uh or as as publishers uh because
uh when you when you start uh
editorializing
uh then you're in a different uh in a
different world and that's why
uh we're bringing forward as you know uh
our measures
are our white paper on online harms uh
because it's time we had a frank
conversation
about the the boundaries
uh that we want to be uh to be set in
the role of these
uh of these companies in uh what they
choose to publish and what they choose
not to publish
well i'm interested to hear that you
agree with uh or at least appear to
appear
agree with chancellor merkel on elements
to your concern there do you also agree
with her
on the european investment treaty that's
just been signed and you also agree with
the chinese government that
the mass sterilization of legal muslims
is a form of gender empowerment
well uh on your on your on your on your
first point about
the the eu uh china deal
um it's it's something that obviously
that we'll
uh will will be studying i think it's
it's very
important that uh i want a world in
which where
uh we're able to uh have good
uh relations with china uh where uh we
were able to interact
freely with china we speak frankly to
china and so
on on the the uyghurs uh i'm with
uh the point that was made by the
foreign secretary uh yesterday
uh i i i i support what what dom rob
had to say but speaking frankly and
calling out
human rights abuses should not uh stop
us from having
a a productive relationship where that
is possible
and i think that's what the british
people want us to see last question
one last question if i may which is that
huawei's chinese employees have either
been recalled to china
or have been forced to leave the company
when they've been expatriates
based in europe and have married a
european this is the
action normally seen in people working
for a government or an intelligence
agency
does this confirm the concerns that many
of us have had that huawei isn't really
a free company but is actually just a
branch of the ministry of state security
in a branch of the chinese state
well the uh
decisions that we've had to take about
uh about our critical national
infrastructure
uh obviously reflect concerns that
i i think you and i share about the
potential for
uh the chinese state to get inside parts
of our
uh our our systems our
uh our internet systems are
uh uh security networks that we
uh wouldn't want to to see and so we you
know we've had to take some
some tough decisions some some
technologically difficult decisions
and some expensive decisions i might say
and the the challenge for us
as as the west as the as the d10 or
indeed the g7
uh is really to come up with the
technological
alternatives and i think it's it's one
thing to
to say well we're going to exclude x or
y company
but what we really want to see is uh
us as uh liberal democracies working
together
to produce the alternative and that
applies not just to technology but also
to our relations
uh with with africa and many other parts
of the world
there you go you're selling the general
agreement on data back to me thank you
prime minister
very good um now we turn to the chair of
the environment audit committee philip
dunn thank you sir
prime ministers uh tom has just referred
i mentioned i'm going to touch on cop 26
and also on greeting and recovery
and i believe darren jones may want to
come in on the back of
the cop 26 questions if there's time in
november
uh that we will be hosting the largest
international conference ever held in
this country on the most important topic
of this century
it's a real opportunity for you to
showcase global britain
leading the world in responding to
climate change
you appointed a full-time president
this month which reflects a call that i
made last year so that's very welcome
alex sharma keeps his seat in the
cabinet without portfolio
you may remember when you were mayor of
london you that jeremy hunt who was then
minister for the olympics
answered questions in the house on uk
preparations for london 2012
will the cop 26 president is subject to
similar scrutiny from members
on his preparations for the glasgow
summit that indeed
that was straightforward
you also acknowledged in pmq's today
that good scrutiny makes for good
government and at present the only
parliamentarians to be included in the
uk delegation to cop 26
are ministers so as head of the uk
delegation will you
demonstrate the importance of proper
scrutiny by inviting chairs and possibly
members of the relevant select
committees
to join the uk delegation to glasgow
um well philip i'll take that away and
look at are you volunteering
yes i'm sure darren is too and there may
be others okay right
well let me let me say then how how let
me
give you a warm welcome in the sense
that i'm sure that you know your
contributions and darren's contribution
will be
uh very useful to what the uk has to say
at
cop but i don't necessarily wish to
allocate places on this or that
uh committee or delegation
right now okay and just finally on cop
there are also as you know
right across the country large numbers
of climate change
activist groups bringing up to try and
see what their local community can do
it would be really helpful i think to
spreading the message
and developing the best practice ideas
not just for this country but across the
world if some of those there could be a
forum
for those groups to input ahead of cop
26
as well would you be prepared to
encourage alex sharma to
facilitate that yes and uh i want i want
the to be the widest possible engagement
with
ngos uh of all kinds uh with civil
society uh everybody who has a a stake
in this and
uh i see no reason why there shouldn't
be a you know
a real festival of ideas in the run-up
to uh to cop
and i know that alok and his team are
very keen on that and
we'll be we'll be seeing what kind of uh
you know whether it's feasible
uh in in glasgow in november to uh to
have
some kind of a fringe uh where uh
because i think the appetite will be
huge
and uh we'll have to to to work out how
to manage it
well that's fantastic can i can i just
bring in darren jones at that point
can i come back yes certainly
thank you suburban prime minister my
committee's leading the parliamentary
scrutiny of the delivery of
cop 26. many have called as we've just
heard for an olympic game style energy
from you personally as prime minister to
ensure that
the uk's leadership of cop 26 is as
successful as the french leadership
of cop25 can i just ask are you
personally interested in
cop and if so what is it that you
personally want to secure
as britain's headline achievement of
running cop26 thank you dan well
there are two things uh i i personally
i'm uh becoming more and more obsessed
with
uh with what we can do because for me to
get back to
the points i was making to tom tukenhart
about
bouncing back from covid the green
agenda
uh the whole green industrial revolution
is not just
a load of green nonsense as people uh
sometimes seem to
suggest an extra cost for for businesses
and for
for families if you do it right it's the
opportunity to to
generate hundreds of thousands of jobs
uh for this country
uh and we we've discussed that uh
earlier
uh you said to me your first question
was what about a
a charter for jobs this is a charter for
jobs uh literally hundreds of thousands
of
jobs in in wind technology in batteries
uh
in in low carbon uh campaigns of all
kinds
and so i so in getting to net zero by
2050
which is the number one objective of of
cop and right and getting
uh the world to to agree to that uh
we have the opportunity to to to turbo
charge
our economy at the same time and uh to
to drive jobs of of all kinds and
so i that that's where i i kind of but
there's a second thing
and that's and that's biodiversity and
uh there it is an absolute tragedy
today that we are massacring
uh the species of our planet we've lost
about
500 in the last uh century uh we're
losing them at an
absolute unconscionable rate we're
losing habitat
where human beings are engulfing
and destroying the natural world and we
won't get the climate
in balance again we won't solve climate
change
until we address our relationship with
the with the natural world so i want
the second big thing in addition to net
zero uh
by 2015 and getting as many countries so
that's a big goal
and lots of and since uh we last spoke i
was lost before this committee
uh lots of countries that we thought
would be difficult have been coming
forward
with commitments uh to net zero uh so
it's it's we're already seeing
darren we're seeing uh even before the
the
year has scarcely begun we're seeing an
enormous amount of progress
but what i want the second thing i want
to see is on biodiversity i want to see
the world
committing in the way that we did in at
kyoto they committed to these aichi
targets
if you remember to protect habitats and
species we want to give
meaning to that now we want countries to
commit
uh solidly and and formally to
stopping the destruction of uh of
animals and wildlife of
of of habitat uh a veget of
uh of forests in the way that they are
mr jones
let's be precise prime minister because
biodiversity is [ __ ] 15 shared by
china yes but we i understand that but
we intend to follow up
with uh with a biodiversity uh the
coming the coming package will be
will be great but we intend uh to use
cop 26 to stress the importance of
biodiversity as well
very good but you said you want to get
every country in the world to agree to
net zero every
50. uh emission right well i think
at the moment we have countries
accounting for about 62 percent of the
population of the world
have made a pledge to net zero uh
which is great uh china as you know is
going for net zero by 2060 which is the
the biggest development since i last
appeared uh before your
uh before your committee but other
countries are now coming through with
net zero by
uh by 2050 and uh it's it's it's
actually very
exciting to see the the way that the a
global
uh consensus is starting to to build and
that
the role of the uk is to the role of the
uk presidency of the cop
is to get as many countries as possible
uh to
to sharing that and even before cop has
begun we're starting to see
uh before our presidency began uh we're
starting to see
uh progress in that direction thank you
mr jones and
is there a possibility we'll have a
non-fossil fuel
treaty well
the the uh the kyoto uh protocol was
intended to reduce
uh on climate change was intended to to
reduce
uh fossil fuel outbut that's the whole
that's the whole point of it
so is the the the paris agreement of
of uh of 2015 and
uh that's what we're that's what we're
trying to do and
back to uh philip dunn thank you prime
minister i was very interested in what
you were saying about biodiversity our
committee was discussing this with the
ministerial team this morning and we've
not met a single one of the aichi
10-year targets so we're really looking
to make proper progress in the next 10
years
but i wanted to raise one quick point
about the greening the recovery
so as part of the the flagship program
uh introduced in the summer partly to
help meet net zero targets but also
support jobs
was the green homes grant scheme and
we've been looking at this
and the tragedy is that the very
short-term nature of this scheme
is regrettably having precisely the
opposite effect
to what was intended with firms
informing builders and
uh installers informing my committee
that it's led them to actually laying
off staff
so a couple of examples one
award-winning company had a full order
book before the grant was announced
now without a single vote well we're
going to leave
questions to the prime minister at the
liaison committee it's been going on for
some two hours now and we're going
across
to washington and to a building that was
under attack
this time last week and is about to make
history again with